[Musique]
deux mois après le lancement d'une
opération militaire dans le sud
d'Arlande afin de stabiliser la région
et mettre fin aux exactions des
ministres tantales le pays fait
aujourd'hui face à une vaste offensive
mercure qui fait craindre le pire
nuit de terreur dans l'Est downl land
après intense bombardement de
l'artillerie
sont fictifs créés pour un exercice
militaire baptisé Orion le plus
important jamais réalisé depuis 30 ans
sur le sol français
imaginez il y a trois ans cet
entraînement interarmé et interallié se
déroulait en France début 2023 tant plus
de 20 départements avec près de 20 000
militaires mobilisés au total
l'objectif se préparer à l'éventualité
d'une guerre moderne pouvant aller
jusqu'à la haute intensité
une perspective qui ne relève plus de la
science-fiction alors que la guerre a
fait son retour sur le continent
européen
plongez avec nous dans les coulisses de
cet exercice hors norme
je vais vous briffer le concept
d'opération pour l'entrée en premier par
la troisième dimension donc l'opération
aéroportée qui se déroulera donc dans la
zone de H4 donc moi je donne le vert
maintenant et après c'est comme à l'OTAN
c'est procédures de silence je fais
simplement un contrôle les deux
composantes se parlent et on revient
vers moi si à un moment donné on a un
doute ou qu'on a besoin que je confirme
quelque chose mais à partir du moment où
la situation tactique et la situation
météo est sur le trait que vous venez de
me décrire c'est vers en avant on sort
un peu de ce qu'on fait depuis 20 ans on
est dans une autre échelle de guerre on
est dans un autre tempo d'opérations
donc on provoque pas systématiquement
des réunions décisionnaires parce que
sinon on s'en sort pas il peut pas dans
les temps qu'on veut donc là moi j'ai
donné un verre donc le vert il est
valable maintenant sauf si un moment
donné on regarde que la météo s'est
dégradée la manœuvre change l'ennemi
changer c'était pas ce qu'on avait prévu
il y a un changement de planification et
ce changement de planification il
impacte toute la guerre à ce moment-là
on retravaille on replanifie mais sinon
c'est bon ok
février 2023 dans le sud de la France
début des opérations l'exercice Orient
est lancé c'est un exercice qui est un
jalon dans la nature des entraînements
que nous avons conduit jusqu'à présent
et qui actent le fait que nous avons
changé de contexte stratégique que nous
sommes désormais dans un contexte avec
des conflits beaucoup plus durs on le
voit aujourd'hui à l'est de l'Europe
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie donc c'est
ce que nous avons acté c'est la nature
des changements des conflits et le fait
que nous devons nous entraîner pour des
guerres que nous pensions oublier ou peu
probable et qui ne sont redevenus
c'est tout l'enjeu de l'exercice le
scénario l'attaque d'un pays fictif
Arnold par son voisin mercure appuyé par
des milices l'exercice se joue en 4
phases après la planification
une intervention aéroportée et amphibie
dans le pays agressé
puis une période de gestion de crise
civile aux militaire et un affrontement
de haute intensité sur le champ de
bataille
Orion a démarré par une campagne
aéromaritime d'entrée en premier
autrement dit la projection en fibi et
aéroportée de force armées sur le
territoire déstabilisé
c'est une capacité qui est difficile à
acquérir parce qu'elle nécessite un
certain nombre de savoir-faire
techniques et de savoir faire tactique
très complet notamment ce qu'on appelle
nous de la projection de puissance donc
la capacité à frapper le dispositif
ennemi dans la profondeur avant de
projeter nos forces avions soldats ou
bateau toutes les nations dans son pas
capables la France fait partie des rares
pays dans le monde être capable
justement de mener ce type d'opération
parce qu'elle dispose des troupes
entraînées pour le faire et surtout
parce qu'elle dispose des moyens pour le
faire que ce soit des moyens de
projection aérien ou des moyens de
projection maritimes
orion est destiné à préparer les armées
au combat de haute intensité contre un
ennemi de force égale
pour comprendre ce que c'est que la
haute intensité je pense qu'il faut
aller un peu dans la sémantique de la
physique c'est à dire que la haute
intensité c'est le quotient de l'énergie
et de la durée c'est-à-dire que on
imagine le l'énergie c'est la violence
c'est les feux c'est les pertes
matérielles et humaines associées et la
durée plus cette violence est appliquée
longtemps et forcément plus les plus les
pertes sont importantes et posent des
difficultés à un pays à une nation alors
les guerres interétatiques avaient
vraiment disparu c'est à dire que le
format c'était plus un contingent
expéditionnaire c'était le format OPEX
pour les armées françaises donc un petit
contingent qui va venir appeler par un
autre état de façon à le renforcer face
à un acteur donc non étatique un groupe
armée terroriste les Gates comme on a pu
avoir dans l'opération barkhane
ici on a séparé y compris dans le
vocabulaire au retour de la haute
intensité depuis la décennie donc 2010
en particulier dans la suite des
printemps arabes avec les conflits qu'on
a vu au Moyen-Orient qu'il a déjà
n'était plus vraiment contre
insurrectionnel on voyait émerger quand
même d'un type de conflit avec le retour
de la bataille en zone urbaine et puis
là février 2022
marqué le ce retour de la guerre en
Europe au format interétatique et là
c'est quelque chose d'assez inédit pour
comparer
cette date de fin février 2022 pour
l'Europe elle est comparable au 11
septembre américain en 2001 parce que
c'est le retour d'un format de guerre
qui a tous les attraits d'un format
historique donc quelque chose qu'on a
connu au 20e siècle en Europe Orion a
été conçu
lors de l'année 2019-2020 donc il faut
pas chercher forcément à comparer la
situation que on cherche à reproduire
dans l'exercice Orion avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en
Ukraine c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait
l'objectif en revanche bien évidemment
on a regardé la façon dont le conflit se
déroule en Ukraine et il y a
certainement des séquences techniques
sur le terrain qui doivent nous
interpeller et donc toutes ces toutes
ces composantes du conflit bien
évidemment les analysés séquencé de
façon à tester nos capacités confrontées
nos capacités lors de l'exercice Orion
assez différents défis les conflits
armés dans un format interétatique qui
ont qui correspondent à ces
caractéristiques de haute intensité dans
la période récente ils sont assez
difficiles à trouver nous sommes
contraints de regarder plus loin dans
l'histoire donc les batailles de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale en particulier
sur le front de l'Est avec déjà ces
villes d'Ukraine qui étaient au centre
des affrontements mais aussi lors de la
première guerre mondiale puisque plus ce
conflit de haute intensité s'inscrit
dans la durée
plus les moyens
hautement technologiques sont difficiles
à produire en raison du temps et plus on
va donc revenir à un format classique
d'affrontement et c'est de cette façon
qu'on voit revenir l'artillerie comme
étant la reine des batailles en Ukraine
jusqu'à la fin la deuxième guerre
mondiale jusqu'à l'apparition de la
diffusion nucléaire
le modèle typique de guerre et là vous
pouvez remonter jusque dans l'Antiquité
c'était de l'affrontement entre
cité-état de l'affrontement entre entre
état entre armée y compris même s'il y
avait des mercenaires et là vous c'est
encore une autre histoire de la guerre
depuis la fin des années 1990 des
décennies de combat asymétriques ou les
opérations de stabilisation et de lutte
contre le terrorisme ont été la priorité
pour les armées elle se prépare
désormais à vivre des conflits plus durs
qui s'exercerait dans tous les domaines
de la conflictualité ce que les
militaires appellent le multimilieux
multichan c'est une façon de
théoriser l'espace de bataille c'est à
dire que des trois dimensions
géographiques naturelles le milieu
maritime aérien et terrestre on a
finalement rajouté d'autres dimensions
on a rajouté déjà deux milieux que sont
le milieu cyber et le milieu spatial et
deux champs le champ informationnel et
le champ électromagnétique qui est
certainement le moins connu peut-être le
plus difficile à appréhender donc de
trois dimensions on est passé à 7
dimensions donc on s'aperçoit avec les
capacités les prouesses technologiques
capable de d'exploiter les milieux de
façon beaucoup plus étendue que par le
passé ce qui en termes de conflictualité
forcément fait peser des menaces
supplémentaires
l'exercice intègre cette dimension
multimillions à tous les niveaux de
l'état-major jusque sur le terrain
dans un exercice dans une opération il y
a toujours trois niveaux de décision et
un niveau stratégique qui est le niveau
où on va concevoir on va fixer les
objectifs politiques de l'opération et
un niveau tactique qui est le niveau du
champ de bataille ou du combat et puis
un niveau opératif c'est le niveau
auquel on se trouve ici qui est le
niveau de la conduite de la campagne et
donc la principale difficulté au niveau
opératif c'est la coordination des
actions que peuvent conduire toutes les
composantes qui contribuent à la
manœuvre terre r mer cyber spatiale
logistique et dans le domaine de la
lutte informationnelle sans oublier les
forces spéciales
c'est l'une des nouveautés les
militaires s'entraînent pour la première
fois grandeur nature à la guerre
informationnelle dans le camp ennemi
tous les coups sont permis
moi je dispose d'un compte sur le réseau
social pour chacun des deux ennemis que
j'incarne et également d'un site
internet qui est géré comme un espace
presse sur lequel je publie des
communiquer de presse la particularité
de ces canaux c'est que
c'est d'ailleurs l'intérêt pour les
joueurs c'est que je ne m'applique pas
les règles que s'applique les armées
françaises j'en ai mis qui n'est pas un
ennemi avec un fonctionnement
démocratique justement pour entraîner
les forces l'ennemi s'autorise
différentes choses alors il fait déjà de
la propagande en déployant des narratifs
voilà qui vont être des narratifs
hostiles à la France des narratifs de
menaces pour déstabiliser la France
l'objectif c'est on va dire de gagner
les coeurs et les esprits et donc
d'influencer une population pour qu'elle
soit hostile à la France nous avons
constaté au cours des derniers mois et
des dernières années en particulier au
sel et en Afrique que si nous prenions
pas garde certains mensonges certaines
manipulations de l'information se
traduisent de manière très concrète dans
le physique par des entraves à notre
liberté d'action j'en veux pour preuve
l'exemple du convoi voit sacré qui qui
cheminait entre un convoi logistique et
cheminait entre Abidjan et Gao au mois
de novembre 2021 qui a été bloqué à
plusieurs reprises sur le simple fait
d'accusation portée contre l'armée
française qui consistait à dire que ce
qu'on voit transporter des munitions et
de l'armement pour les groupes armées
terroristes et donc les populations qui
croyaient à ces fausses informations
vous voulez arrêter le convoi pour le
contrôler ce qui était bien sûr pas
possible pour des raisons de sécurité on
a vu se développer ces derniers temps
c'est donc un usage planifié et
coordonné en particulier par des acteurs
comme Wagner les acteurs russes tout
simplement qui vont
industrialiser la production des
informations et qui vont donc faire de
l'outil Internet de l'outil du
smartphone une arme c'est-à-dire que la
désinformation va venir vous toucher
jusque dans votre écran personnalisé et
va vous enfermer dans une bulle
informationnelle qui va être renforcée
par les algorithmes l'idée donc c'est de
trouver les moyens de percer cette bulle
dans laquelle n'importe quel type de
citoyen et y compris nos soldats y
compris nos militaires pourront être
soumis à de l'influence et pourront voir
le doute s'instiller en eux en raison de
cette désinformation
tout au long de l'exercice les
militaires sont plongés dans un
environnement numérique et
informationnel simuler pour l'occasion
la lutte informationnelle dans
l'exercice Orion c'est quelque chose
expérimental de complètement
expérimental que l'on a testé grâce à
l'appui d'une société qui s'appelle la
société chrysotech qui nous a mis à
disposition un certain nombre d'outils
et de plateformes pour pouvoir simuler
et animer cet environnement
informationnel c'est la première fois
que l'on opère que l'on génère un tel
environnement dans le cas d'un exercice
c'est la première fois on n'est jamais
allé aussi loin dans la simulation et
l'animation de l'environnement
informationnel et de la lutte
informationnelle nous ici on est là pour
mettre en place la simulation de
l'environnement international et pour
l'animer donc on anime du côté des
rouges et on anime également sur
l'intégralité du spectre informationnel
avec les opinions publiques les journaux
français les médias etc etc tout ça
fonctionne avec à peu près 25000 robots
qui fonctionnent sur la plateforme et
qui ont généré depuis le début de
l'exercice 282 000 réactions sur le
système
sur le terrain aussi des actions
médiatiques auxquelles s'ajoutent des
pressions psychologiques de l'adversaire
comme des manifestations des tags où
l'envoi de tract appelant à la haine
la première chose qu'on attend d'une
unité qui constate à son niveau qu'elle
a été victime d'une d'action
d'intoxication c'est qu'elle rende
compte qu'elle a vu quelque chose ou
voilà donc concrètement physiquement des
joueurs sont équipés deux téléphones
portables dédiés spécifiques pour capter
des images intéressantes qui puisse être
ensuite réutilisés par l'échelon
au-dessus tactique jusqu'au niveau
stratégique et c'est à partir de
l'analyse et donc de la l'analyse qui va
permettre de déterminer la dangerosité
de cette fausse information que l'on va
mettre en place des tactiques ou des
stratégies de contrats qui vont
permettre d'élaborer les messages qui
vont contrer justement la fausse
information adverse en fait produire du
contenu c'est ça ça revient à mener une
des actions très différentes il y a la
capacité à documenter ce que nous
faisons avec un enjeu de transparence
voire de rapidité c'est-à-dire être
capable de très vite produire des images
preuves par exemple pour démonter des
accusations c'est ce que nous avons fait
en avril 2022 avec l'affaire du charnier
de Gossip où nous avons mis en évidence
une attaque informationnelle contre les
armées françaises menées par les
mercenaires de Wagner et la meilleure
arme pour lutter contre les
manipulations de l'information et contre
les attaques informationnelles c'est la
liberté de la presse c'est permettre aux
journalistes de faire leur travail
[Musique]
Orion permet aussi de travailler
l'intéropérabilité avec plusieurs des
partenaires de la France tout comme la
capacité à tenir le rôle de nations
cadres un enjeu crucial pour la haute
intensités soit au sein de l'Alliance
atlantique ou de l'Union européenne soit
au sein d'une coalition qu'on dit ADOX
c'est-à-dire avec des pays qui pour la
circonstance sont prêts à agir avec nous
comment le fait par exemple dans un
certain nombre de théâtres et être
nationcadre c'est être la nation qui va
commander l'opération et qui notamment
va fournir les moyens de commandement
pour commander l'opération et ça aussi
ça fait partie des capacités rares dont
dispose les armées françaises
effectivement pour ce genre d'opérations
qui sont extrêmement lourdes extrêmement
complexes
on ne pourra le faire que avec des
alliés on a des capacités tous des
capacités assez
assez phénoménal assez énorme mais
seulement
l'intégration de chacune de ces
capacités au sein d'un commandement
unique qu'il soit français dans ce cas
puisque nous sommes nationales
permettront de vaincre un adversaire
avec une une masse suffisante
sur les 12000 militaires commandés par
le général Gaulin pour la phase
d'affrontement dans l'Est de la France
1700 soldats sont étrangers
issus de 14 nationalités différentes un
engagement inédit
les opérations de combat à grande
échelle sont les opérations les plus
complexes que nous menons donc si nous
pouvons maîtriser ces opérations nous
pouvons opérer à n'importe quel niveau y
compris les opérations d'urgence de
stabilité et de soutien si nous avons
appris quelque chose de l'histoire c'est
que les alliances sont d'une importance
cruciale oui oui nous vivons dans un
monde de plus en plus interconnecté
diplomatiquement politiquement
socialement économiquement et
militairement ces exercices nous
permettent de développer
l'interopérabilité et la compréhension
pour tirer se déplacer et communiquer
sur le champ de bataille le plus ne nous
entraînons et nous nous comprenons dont
sur le plan culturel que dans nos
systèmes le mieux nous sommes en mesure
de combattre ensemble en tant
qu'alliance
ok les gars je vous explique
certainement en tout cas pour un petit
pays comme la Belgique on va très
rarement s'engager tout seul donc on va
généralement faire partie d'une
coalition et pour ça il y a rien à faire
il faut s'entraîner ensemble encore et
encore pour mettre en place des
procédures que tout le monde comprend
mettre en place aussi des passerelles
techniques qui permettent de se parler
de communiquer et donc ça ça ne peut se
faire que avec de l'entraînement
régulier quand on parle d'intervabilité
on pense aux radios qui simplement doit
pouvoir se parler on doit pouvoir
communiquer entre nous mais en fait
c'est beaucoup plus que ça c'est avant
tout une interopérabilité je pense
interpersonnelle donc il faut pouvoir
comprendre avec qui on va travailler
pour voir comprendre les différences de
culturelles et pouvoir finalement
vraiment collaborer et tirer meilleur
profit de chacun pour pouvoir être
meilleur à deux plutôt que chacun
séparément les armées ils travaillent
depuis longtemps du seul enjeu militaire
le défi est national Orion intègre aussi
une dimension civile autrement dit tous
les services de l'État qui pourraient
être touchés par le conflit imaginé pour
étudier leur capacité à résister et à
soutenir les armées la réflexion sur les
forces morales les enjeux politiques et
sociaux de la préparation à la haute
intensité on les synthétise en une
notion un concept qui est celui de
résilience de la nation l'idée
principale étanque de cette résilience
que en dépit d'une attaque puissante
forte rapide d'un acteur doté de toutes
ces composantes notre état nos forces
soient capables de résister à cette
première attaque et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles dans l'exercice
Orion au tout début il a été imaginé une
phase civile au militaire parce que il
était évident pour les concepteurs de
l'exercice que on ne pouvait pas se
projeter dans cette fiction avec
simplement un engagement militaire il
fallait penser la mobilisation nationale
tout autour et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que on est venu à la rencontre
d'une initiative du secrétariat général
de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale qui travaillait sur la
stratégie nationale de résilience
nous faire l'honneur de votre présence
pour cet exercice interministériel qui
est majeur qui s'inscrit donc
effectivement dans l'exercice Orion et
qui avait pour objectif de marquer que
au côté du ministère des armées
chevilles ouvrières de l'exercice Orion
l'ensemble de l'État les administrations
centrales mais aussi les administrations
territoriales et on l'a vu les
collectivités locales et les citoyens et
les associations doivent pouvoir se
mettre en ordre de bataille pour pouvoir
soutenir un effort de guerre qui à la
fois a eu lieu à l'extérieur mais aurait
aussi un impact sur notre territoire
national et sur le fonctionnement de
notre société je pense que l'aptitude
d'un état s'imposer face à ces
compétiteurs adversaires ennemis ne
dépend pas uniquement de la compétence
de ces armées mais c'est également la
compétence ou la performance de
l'appareil d'État qui conditionne les
conditionnera le succès on a découvert
lorsqu'on a eu la crise du covid après
les tâtonnements du début quand en fait
notre pays notre société notre peuple
avait des ressources extraordinaires
pour pouvoir s'organiser ce coordonner
et faire en sorte que même quand on
était en confinement on arrivait
toujours à se nourrir à se soigner à
avoir un certain nombre de services
rendus
sur un conflit à haute intensité il faut
que ce soit la même chose ça va des
sujets juridiques parce que est-ce que
en réquisitionne est-ce qu'on fait des
contrats comment ça se passe quel est le
cadre juridique ça va des sujets
logistiques quelles entreprises sont
capables de fournir des camions des
trains des avions ça va sur les sujets
stocks on a beaucoup parlé d'économies
de guerre et en fait dans l'économie de
guerre vous avez deux dimensions vous
avez d'abord la nécessité que
l'industrie de défense soit capable de
produire plus plus vite et dans de
meilleures circonstances ce qui veut
dire qu'en droit il faut aussi qu'on
puisse sans doute modifier les textes
pour lui permettre de travailler plus et
de fournir un certain nombre d'éléments
et puis après il y a l'autre aspect qui
est justement d'organiser notre économie
de corriger nos règles de marché public
pour faire en sorte que face à une
situation exceptionnelle une situation
d'urgence on puisse être en situation
d'agir et de réagir vite et de ne pas se
retrouver coincé par des normes ou par
des procédures qui sont utiles et même
nécessaires en temps de paix mais qui en
tant de crise entrave font perdre du
temps il risque de coûter des vies 2
packs et demi juste sur la butée
la 5 m mais je sais pas si on a un qui
mord ou pas en plus de l'adaptation du
droit et des normes Orion permet de
mesurer l'importance des réserves
nationales un renfort jugé indispensable
dans un scénario de haute intensité
de nombreux réservistes ont été
mobilisés pendant l'exercice
passe une grande chance d'être là et bah
on a travaillé avec la brigade cynophile
donc on a eu beaucoup de ressentis de de
des militaires qui étaient là bas on a
eu beaucoup de d'informations sur ce qui
faisait bah j'ai découvert des régiments
j'ai découvert comment il travaillait
j'ai découvert comment ça se mettait en
place
comment il se répartissaient sur sur les
camps comment comment ils travaillent
sur le terrain ça c'est la première fois
je vois ça je trouve que c'est super
important d'avoir des réservistes
surtout au sein des exercices comme ça
parce qu'on est le premier lien entre
les la vie civile et l'armée les la
nation et l'armée et ça nous permet de
parler au quotidien à des gens de tous
les jours qui sont qui connaissent pas
du tout l'armée ça nous permet de
sensibiliser à ça parce qu'on peut avoir
beaucoup d'apriori sur l'armée et
puis les gens en fait ça ils nous pose
ils nous pose des questions et on leur
répond parce qu'on est dedans et bah là
je vais je vais pouvoir leur répondre un
peu plus parce que je connais un peu
mieux maintenant le terrain et tout tous
les régiments qui est ici léo est
étudiant dans l'audiovisuel Mathieu
vient de terminer des études de finance
et soit désormais s'engager réserviste
depuis un an ils se sont portés
volontaire pour participer à l'exercice
alors en tant que service nous servons
de différentes façons d'émissions telles
que des checkpoint pour contrôler les
véhicules de la force ennemi des
missions de surveillance de zones de
renseignements des missions de combat
avec des actions où il faut s'emparer
par exemple de cage de munitions ou
d'aller au contact directement qui m'a
beaucoup plu dans la mission Orion c'est
principalement de travailler avec les
alliés
nos camarades britanniques américains
belges et autres de voir différents
véhicules que nous n'avons pas en tant
que réserviste l'occasion de voir
souvent et de vivre des missions à deux
et intensité j'aime beaucoup les
réservistes sont des des gens qui sont
qui sont pas importants ils sont
essentiels en fait pour notre pour notre
exercice mais pour notre vie de tous les
jours et pour nos opérations en général
j'en ai de l'or 2000 ici sur le sur le
l'opération alors plusieurs rôles dans
un premier temps j'ai beaucoup
d'officiers d'état-major de
sous-officiers d'état-major qui sont des
spécialistes dans certains domaines qui
sont complètement intégrés dans les
états majeurs à tous les niveaux que ce
soit au niveau du corps d’armée au
niveau de la division au niveau des
brigades au niveau des régiments et
deuxième temps j'ai des unités de
réserviste qui ont des missions de
protection qui ont des missions
d'intervention ils ont des savoir-faire
qui sont très utiles qui sont en train
de se durcir aussi tout comme l'armée
d'actifs se durcit l'armée de notre
réserve est en train de se durcir mais
c'est effectivement une composante
absolument critique pour nous
les ministères des armées compte
actuellement 40 000 réservistes
opérationnels
ce nombre devrait doubler dans les
prochaines années
Orient c'est achevée au début du mois de
mai après trois semaines d'affrontement
dans les plaines du Grand Est
[Musique]
la France a prévu de renouveler
l'opération tous les trois ans prochaine
étape donc l'année 2026 pour une
nouvelle édition de cet exercice
[Musique]